this video is brought to you by
squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website we've been testing out
the lg graham 14
for about a week now and it's quickly
become one of our favorite windows
laptops of all time
for four different reasons that i'm
gonna be talking about in this review
but it also has two big issues i'll talk
about both the pros and the cons that
you should know about
if you're considering buying one and how
it compares to a few windows laptops
along with apple's n1 max
and then i'll give you my conclusion on
if you should buy one of these
or if not let's jump right into it let's
start out with the biggest feature
the weight even after spending a week
with a gram
i am still shocked by how lightweight it
is
each and every time that i pick it up
even literally right now
it is almost surreal the weight is
literally
in grams not kilograms like most laptops
being 30 to 40 percent lighter than the
dell xps or macbook pro or the air
while having a bigger battery and a
bigger display there are some downsides
though
the laptop is noticeably thicker than
others and not only because of the extra
ports which could be blamed
but also because of how thick the lid is
even the display
isn't a touch screen that needs to be
thicker with that there is a ton of flex
both in the lid and in the body and i
have never seen
this much flex in any laptop even
plastic ones that cost a few hundred
dollars
the body itself is made from magnesium
alloy so it's not plastic
but that doesn't stop it from feeling
like plastic and
a lot less premium than its biggest
competitors that are made
from super solid aluminum and all of
this brings me to a question
does being noticeably lighter in weight
actually matter
if the laptop is thicker and it ends up
going into a backpack or a bag
anyway where the weight difference isn't
really that noticeable
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below now let's focus on
other aspects starting with
ports the bearer plug from last year is
gone and we now charge with usb type-c
and either one of the two thunderbolt 4
ports
that are on the left-hand side lg
included a 65-watt brick but the gram
can accept up to 100 watts for faster
charging
and we also have a full size hdmi and a
headphone jack
on the opposite side we have a micro sd
card slot and two super speed
standard size usb ports which is
becoming extremely rare for ultrabooks
especially for ones that are this
lightweight along with a lockport now
before i mention
more class leading aspects for the gram
let me give a shout out to something
else that is class leading
our sponsor squarespace if you've been
thinking about making your own website
now is the perfect time and squarespace
is seriously the best way to go
you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience and it doesn't matter if you
want a portfolio
a blog e-commerce or anything else you
just choose a template and customize
blocks of text and images
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
and ours have been running flawlessly
for years now
bringing in lots of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com
maxtec or by using our custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
you will save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain taking a look at the inside i
have to praise how clean the gram looks
with larger keys and trackpad this year
which are both very good it is crazy how
almost every laptop manufacturer has
really stepped up their game the last
few years
and i want to say that the keyboard is
class-leading because it's fantastic but
so is the dells and razors and the same
thing with the diving board trackpad
and like most new laptops the power
button also doubles as a fingerprint
scanner for easy and quick logins
but unfortunately we are missing the
windows hello face
unlock my only other complaint with the
inside here
is the chassis flex when you're clicking
the trackpad towards the top
because of this i just ended up using
the tap method and it was very accurate
and responsive
and although the finish feels a little
bit plasticky
one benefit is it is very resistant to
fingerprints
moving up to the display there is a
whole lot of good
and really only one issue i have to say
that i'm so glad that 16 by 10 is
finally mainstream
in these small laptops because the extra
vertical space is really noticeable and
useful what's also noticeable is that
the lg screen is a 14 inch which doesn't
sound like much
bigger than a 13 or 13.4 inch screen but
i could definitely tell the difference
every time i open it up
i also love how bright the display is
coming in at 500 nits
and lg also claims that it supports dc
ip3 white colors with at least 95
accuracy which is great my only
complaint with the display
is how reflective it is now for most
people it won't be an
issue since it will likely be better
than their previous laptop thanks to the
high brightness but if you're trying to
turn down the brightness to save battery
life or you're using it outside
or even in a room like this where i have
lots of light you definitely see the
reflections
and because of the reflections contrast
is also noticeably worse
than say a macbook pro now to me this
doesn't really make sense since
lg is literally one of the biggest and
best display manufacturers
and dell's xps has an almost identical
panel to this
as far as technology and brightness and
everything else but it is actually even
less reflective
than the macbook pro as for resolution
we only have
one option a 1200p based screen which is
noticeably less sharp than a 2.6 k or a
4k that's in a mac or an xps
but it will work for most people and
there are definitely benefits
to battery life which we'll talk about
in just a bit above the display we have
a 720p
webcam which is standard spec but that
doesn't tell you the whole story
when we actually look at the video
quality it is quite dark and dull
looking
and while the microphone is really loud
clarity is also lower than average
here's how it compares to a macbook and
now let's compare the webcam and
microphone quality
this is the 720p webcam from the lg
gram and this is the webcam and
microphone quality with the new
m1 macbook air and now let's get another
downside out of the way and that
is the speakers they are louder than
average like the microphones but they
are also very flat
if you're going to listen to say a
podcast or a simple video it will be
fine it'll do the job but if you want to
listen to music or watch
movies they are a bit disappointing go
ahead and take a listen for yourself
[Music]
and now let's finally get into
performance and i want to start out with
the ssd
which is one of the fastest i have seen
in an ultrabook
even with a base 256 gig model
um it was actually hitting almost 3 000
megabytes per second
where most 256 gig windows laptops are
about half of that speed
and you have to step up to say a one
terabyte to get a really fast ssd
with that the ssd is not soldered which
is becoming the standard for these
ultrabooks
and to make things even better lg gave
us a whole nother m.2 ssd slot
that is completely unused so you can add
another ssd later
without having to replace the original
one i have to say that this
is a huge selling point for the lg gram
the absolute biggest benefit of the lg
gram is that the performance does not
drop
at all when you unplug it this is not
the case with many of the windows
laptops out there which lose drastic
amounts of performance when unplugged
even ultrabooks like the xps 13. on top
of that the other thing i really like
about it is that the fans
don't get crazy loud which is both a
good and a bad
thing it's very nice if you're doing a
lot of tasks that need quick and short
bursts of power
like say for a couple minutes so you
don't have to deal with huge spikes and
fan noise like you can get with xps or
the razer
it is probably the quietest windows
ultrabook that i have ever used
however lg's focus on low fan noise
unfortunately kills performance for
longer term workflows
and even some shorter tasks because they
are choosing to limit
frequency and wattage to keep the system
cool enough instead of ramping up the
fans
and this is software locked as well
taking a look at the 11 gen i5
performance it comes quite
short of the xps 13 with the same exact
i5 cpu
in geekbench 5 because of the wattage
limits that lg puts in
resulting in about a 15 difference in
performance now in terms of single core
the performance is very close so you
won't be able to tell a difference in
regular tasks like opening apps and web
browsing
and you'll also benefit from a quieter
system now when we push the limits of
the cpu the difference is substantial
about 23 even though they use the same
exact tiger lake chip
but what does this mean in the real
world well we exported
50 edited 42 megapixel raw images from
lightroom classic and the lg took 4
minutes and 43 seconds
compared to 3 minutes and 11 seconds
with the xps thankfully as far as
graphics the performance is practically
the same in geekbench 5 and for gaming
and gfx bench
it was actually slightly higher but when
we combine the cpu
and the gpu say for video editing it
takes
30 minutes to export a 5 minute 4k
project in premiere while the xps 13
takes under 20 minutes now as you may
have noticed i haven't been talking
about the new m1 macbooks performance
because most windows laptop shoppers
will want to stick with windows machines
but that same 5-minute 4k task finished
in less than 10 minutes
all while staying about as quiet as the
lg
now lg does offer the gram with an i7
processor if you need more performance
but the i7 only reaches the level of the
i5
in the dell xps 13. so if you care about
performance more than portability and
quietness
then i would say skip the lg now the
other thing that i haven't talked about
is battery life and that's a major
strong suit of the gram for two reasons
the first is directly related to cpu
power being limited
so the wattage stays down and the second
is for the really large
battery coming in at 72 watt hours
whereas the dell has a 52 watt hour
battery because of this you get a great
nine hours of real-world battery life
compared to seven with the dell
if you have the same resolution display
or about five hours if you have the 4k
screen
so overall if you're looking for a great
all-around windows ultrabook for regular
use the lg
delivers but if you need performance
check out our reviews of the xps
or the razer book i'll go ahead and link
both those videos along with the links
to my recommended machines
down in the video description the other
option is buying an
m1 macbook air which is both cheaper and
faster
and it doesn't have some of the
downsides of the gram go ahead and check
out my full comparison
right over there and go ahead and click
above to subscribe to see more videos
like this one
and to help us reach 600 000 subscribers
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i'll see you in the next
video